one of the great things about working
for HBO is they they have shown not only
on my show but on on a variety of their
other shows beforehand shows like The
Sopranos and Boardwalk Empire and and
other shows that they're they're willing
to present as the center or central
characters of their shows very flawed
and human characters who are full of
contradictions I mean a character like
Tony Soprano who is at one point a
family man who obviously deeply loves
his his children and he loves his wife
which doesn't prevent him from [ __ ]
around with all sorts of other random
women that he encounters and you know
you'll see him feeding the ducks at his
at his back at his backyard pool and
being very upset that the Ducks have
flown away and then a couple acts later
he sees a guy who owes him money and he
runs him over with the car and gets out
and starts kicking him in the head and
yet you you do you like Tony Soprano I
don't know if you if you like Tony
Soprano or not but you certainly find
him fascinating yeah and I think you do
find him sympathetic on some level his
humanity makes you kind of want to root
for him but then he starts kicking
someone in the head and you sort of have
to examine whoa why am i rooting for him
what am i doing there at you know that's
what a reaction to me is is very healthy
and the frustration about working for a
traditional network television is that
for for most of the history certainly
the period I was working for them they
were not interested in presenting anyone
that was that was flawed or or unlikable
and and you know they were trying to
pretest everything with their focus
groups and all that and one incident
from my own career after Beauty and the
Beast I did development and I wrote a
number of pilots for them only one of
which was filmed which was a an
alternate world show called doorways and
in the opening sequence of doorways it's
a it's a parallel world show this sort
of feral girl from from an alternate
dimension appears suddenly in the middle
of a freeway on earth you know at night
and all this all that she's never been
on a free
she's never seen cars or trucks before
and they're all these vehicles rushing
at her at high rates of speed you know
and she has this alien weapon with her
this gun that shoots explosive needles
and the cars are all honking and all
that and they're slamming into each
other as they try to avoid this this
person on foot who suddenly appeared in
the middle of the freeway and then she
sees this huge tanker truck coming
toward her and it can't possibly get out
of the way it starts to break and it
starts to jackknife and it's obviously
gonna hit her and kill her so she whips
out the alien weapon and blows - out of
it and it's a spectacular sequence that
it was in you know was in the script and
it got proved all the way through it's
the opening scene of the of the thing
and done right it could it should have
been very effective here and we're
reaching the screening stage and
suddenly the network realizes something
and I say wait a minute
what happened to the driver at a tanker
truck well she blew the [ __ ] out of him
he's he's dead oh no oh no we can't have
that he's just an innocent teamster he's
just driving his truck and suddenly
there's this girl and he breaks he tries
to avoid her he doesn't deserve to die I
said well no but you know she doesn't
know I need that she just sees this a
big iron thing heading toward her and
she has this weapon it'll stop it from
killing her so she uses it it's like a
monster well yes but if she kills this
teamster this truck driver the audience
will hate her no one watched a show
they'll turn it off right there oh I'm
not gonna watch a show about a murderer
we never even see this guy we don't see
a driver we see a truck coming at us and
she blows it up you know I'm saying
Shido it's just not gonna care that I
ever gonna realize that there's a guy in
the truck no one's gonna make this
intellectual thing but no no the network
the network was locked in on that so we
had to go back and boot up the cameras
again and shoot a scene where the driver
unharmed leaps from the flaming truck
and goes running away scampering safety
so we know even though his truck is is
Llyod pieces all over the sidewalk that
no harm has come to innocent Joe the
truck driver who has gone home to his
wives and children so the focus group
would like my character and not dislike
her because she blew up the truck so
that's the difference to be working for
HBO and working for a network
[Laughter]